[Musique]
l'espace rédelé du bas de la rivière
saint-denis complète les centres de
vaccination qu'ovide mise à disposition
par le département ce site permet aux 19
7 4 de vacciner en toute sécurité
les professionnels de santé et
maintenant les personnes de plus de 75
ans et donc à tous ceux qui doutent
aujourd'hui des bienfaits de la
vaccination en général je rappellerai
autorités sanitaires que la vaccination
sécurité un des piliers fondamentaux des
progrès de la médecine des trois gros
principes qui fondent la stratégie
vaccinale mise en oeuvre en france et
donc ici né à la réunion c'est
l'efficacité la sécurité et la
transparence
donc les gens arrivent ici initialement
ils ont plus rendez vous sur un site
c'est une plate forme donc normalement
ils ont rendez vous est donc là adieu la
première vaccination
le premier à se faire vacciner s'en
souviendra longtemps même si suivre ce
parcours semble une formalité
les choses sont très encadrés le
transporteur lui-même n'a que 10 heures
devant lui pour transporter en toute
sécurité
ces flacons une fois qu'ils sont sorti
du congélateur tout ça veut dire qu on a
quand même prévu que chaque sens soit
d'histoire a provisionné 2 à 3 fois par
semaine actuellement le département
compte huit centres de vaccination dont
quatre comme ici en ambulatoire
l'idée est de répondre à l'exigence
sanitaire déficiences et d'accessibilité
géographique ou non les parties
ça va c'est bon bon
ah oui d'espagne face au barça carles
deuxième tour donc va tu voudras la
deuxième piqûre à faire donc elle va au
contact à vous directement là où
l'attendent encore comme en 15 minutes
pour être sûr que tout va bien et il
peut avoir des effets indésirables
pendant les gens qui suivent un petit
peu de fièvre un peu de mal aux
pratiques 80 personnes peuvent se faire
vacciner quotidiennement ainsi sur
rendez-vous tout le monde est maintenant
invitée à se faire vacciner
dans ce cadre historique on n'a pas
d'autre solution aujourd'hui il est
important de se vacciner j'ai sonné dans
l'espace régler un espace qui était à
l'époque occupé par un médecin
l'autorisé qui a participé à aux
premières campagnes de vaccination
contre la variole dans la commune donc
je crois que il faut tout faire pour se
faire vacciner
c'est important pour soi mais c'est
aussi important pour son entourage et
pour la collectivité
et puis comme contre un loyer tout et
monsieur s'est bien passé à l'âme mais
ramenez-nous deux personnes de mon
entourage
exactement voilà c'est comme ça qu'on
avance et
[Musique]